SKYROCKET IF DeSANTIS DID PUSH
AHEAD WITH4 RUN. SHE?
RANDI KAY HAS HER
>> HELLO, EVERYONE, M SEY
BEFORE SHE WASTHS
CKSONVIL TT BEHIND TO RAISE HER
CHILDREN AND HERHIS RUN   DeSAN
BORN IN  AJI
ECONOMICS DEGREEONH
THE GOLF RGET THE UNIVERSITY
OF FLORIDA.
T LOOKING OVER MER BECE
BU
R THERE.
LOOKING
AN ATTRACTION?
URSE, HE WAS CUTE.
R COUPLE MARRIED F 2009 AT THET
DISNEY WORLD R
CASEY WORKED FOR AOSPGA
TOUR, APPEARING ON THE GOLF
CHANNEL.
LATER
HE CONGRESSIONAL
DISTRICT, THE START OF HISLITICR
ADVISE HER HUSBA OMEDIA NECI TVE
STRATEGY AND APPEAR IN CAMPAIGN
ADS, INCLUDINGHIS MEMORABLE
ONE FROM 2018. WALL.TE
AIN.T TONON
DeSANTIS REALLIS?
Y COAING OW  MORRE
HE HELPED HER R 2021 REAS.W  HT
OFEN
TO FIGHT FORF.HEEN
THAT IS WHO RON DeSANTISS. WHENY
WITH THE THREE YOUNG CHILDREN,N
CAGN TRAIL.
>> RWANT YOU TO S
G FOR THE RIGHT REASONT CA TO
IT BE WANTS TOINGS.
>> ReporteN E AFTERMATH OFRR THE
DISASTERIEF FUND SHE
OVERSEES BHT$50 MILLION.
LL I CAN SAY I
OUR HEARTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH SO MANYE WHO ARE
SUFFERING, WHICH IS WHS O HED T
ReporELECTION NIGHT THI
THS
GOVERNOR SHINING A O
HIS WIFE
LADY IT IMPORTANT OF ALLANK YOUI